سيد مصطفى انتم كم كيف تقراون هذه النتائج
حتى الان
يبدو ان الجوله الثانيه اصبحت شبه حتميه
ومنذ عام 2018 الى اليوم نجد بان رجب طيب
اردوغان لم يستطيع ان يقوم بزياده اصواته
حيث نجد ان هناك عدم الزياده في 12
مدينه ثم ايضا بعد
التصريحات التي صدرت عنه وكاله
الاناضول او من خلال البيانات والارقام
ايضا
نجد ان اصوات الرئيس اردوغان دائما كانت
ظاهره ثم التراجع دليل بان هناك نوع من
التلاعب في نقل البنايت ولك بيانات ولكن
كما قال السيد احمد نحن في نهايه الامر
ديمقراطي وهذا سباق ديمقراطي
ولا شك انه فيه الجوله الثانيه قرار سنان
اورانج هو سيكون الحاسم لان سنان اوغان
اذا ما وقف الى جانب تحالف الشعب لا شك ان
الامر سيكون ضد
نعم رجب طيب اردوغان ولا ننسى ان هناك
ايضا عدد كبير ممن لم يصوتوا لم يذهبوا
الى صناطق الاقتراع نحن الان طبعا سننتظر
12 مليون صوت كيف سيكون تكون نتيجته
واضافه الى ذلك ايضا
ستكون هناك اعتراضات وسنرى النتيجه
النهائيه غدا ولكن حسب ما نراه ان هذه
الدوله الاولى كانت
لصالح
رجب طيب اردوغان وان كان هو يتصدر لكن
هناك حقيقه ان رجب طيب اردوغان لم يستطع
ان يزيد
التاييد الشعب او يزيد اصواته ثم ايضا انا
اعتقد ان ربما بعض التطورات الاخيره
انعكست على صناديق الاختراع
وايضا
وهذا ما ارىه انا اعتقد ان الجميع سيحترم
القرار قرار الشعب
وتعرفون ان هناك بعض الشائعات ايضا
نعم هل الرئيس اردوغان اذا ما
انهزم هل سيسلم السلطه ام لا وقد ادلى
بتصريح قبيله الانتخابات وقال انا ساحترم
اراده الشعب فهذا شيء جيد
وانا اظن انه رجب طيب اردوغان اذا ما فاز
في الجوله الثانيه اعتقد انه سيعيد النظر
في سلوكه ربما في
تليين خطاباته نوعا ما واقامه علاقات جوار
افضل واعتقد ان السنان اوغان هو سيكون
ربما المحدد والحاسم لنتيجه الجوله
الثانيه